Four of the most important things every woman needs in a relationship.
Achieve all of these and you'll be able to keep any high value,
marriage material woman in your life
number one- whatever woman needs is you to be her security.
meaning you value her and you put her first,
She knows that she's the only girl for you,
you don't entertain any other woman that isn't her.
Not only that,
you don't ignore her when you're hanging out with your friends,
keep her in the loop,
be her security.
number two- give her validation
this means having those hard conversations
when she ask you where you stand in the relationship.
take the relationship seriously so she's not questioning you.
you need to assure her,
make sure that her emotions are being understood and that she feels seen.
No. 3- give her enough attention
this could be as simple as writing her a cute note,
or sending her thoughtful text throughout the day.
You also need to be affectionate with her,
give her a hug,
give her a smooch on the forehead,
women love that and melt for that.
And don't forget to compliment her.
Is she wearing a new outfit?
is she wearing her hair differently?
Make sure you notice and compliment her on that.
that's all any woman wants is to feel seen and complimented
praise her
No. 4- this should come as a no brainer but you have to, put in the effort
do not avoid having hard,
vulnerable conversations if she's trying to have them with you
to understand you better.
Also make sure you're making enough time for her,
life gets busy,
but as long as you're trying to see her,
that's all any woman wants
put in the effort to hang out
take her out on dates or simply just make her dinner
just put an effort so she knows that you care about her
that's all any woman wants
if you put an effort,
she will see that and stay.
and put an effort to communicate your needs and her needs so you both are happy
Achieve all of these,
and you'll be able to keep any high value woman that you want in your life.